I have to say I was thinking about this
tonight in the in the apocalypse in the
apocalypse of all the characters I would
want me shown while I'm watching my back
I think you are the most badass and I'll
tell you why I actually did the research
we actually looked into it total Walker
kill count look at that right there
[Applause]
but despite that despite that I would
still want to be with you well you
haven't bad came of the show a little
later yeah we actually broke it down
into average kills I think we have that
here everybody with all these folks I
mean everybody is amazing do you like
now shown that you are your character is
like that Michonne is in a position of
authority now that she's actually sort
of the constable do you don't I mean of
this time do you like that part of the
role I mean we don't know where she is
exactly right now I mean she had to take
that sword back so what kind of it is
kind of this question of where she is
she never really wanted to be the
constable she put that thing on because
she was trying to find a place where
these guys could integrate and they
could actually be a part of a community
and she you know there has to be some
give-and-take we can't walk up in their
spot eat their food live in their houses
and say we're not gonna do anything you
can that's the that's the conflict in
the group is the question of how do we
integrate or not and that was what was
happening between her and her and Rick
at the end of the season which led to a
couple tense moments